son rayon que son rayon est ce que vous
êtes du genre très ordonnée à la maison
parce que c'est propre à bordeaux après
si y'a pas du tout pas trop à bon nombre
de patrons ça veut dire bordélique je la
connais je me vois pas trop sèche je
respecte les les mesures d'hygiène
nécessaires
les enfants dont l hôpital ben ali la
corde même si cool quoi très bien
d'accord caroline ne coule pas du tout
d'accord on va écouter
alors il ya peut-être une information
qui pourrait vous réconcilier toutes les
deux puisque aux états unis un père de
famille a eu une surprise un truc assez
incroyable au moment de rentrer chez lui
je vous en dis pas plus et le 12 45 de
m6 qui nous raconte cette petite
histoire
quelqu'un s'est introduit à votre
domicile en votre absence
rien n'a été volé mais la maison a été
nettoyé c'est la mésaventure qu'a
raconté sur facebook cet habitant de
boston
le père de famille a prévenu la police
est ce qu'on en pense le rêve
enfin c'est quelqu'un qui s'introduit
chez vous mais pour nettoyer il oui
d'accord mais tu l'as tu vas y ont livré
bataille et bah c'est pas grave écoute
s'il me laisse une maison comme ça il
peut aller dans mes culottes
il me met la maison comme ça je leur
donne même une c'est venir à bombay le
côté très bien pour s'introduire chez
vous passez vous faites on peut
s'introduire dans votre maison mais
presque prête à les lâcher mon adresse
pour avoir une surprise
on va écouter c'est pas ça ne va pas ça
ne fait pas ça aux caroline qu'est ce
que vous en pensez à ce que c'est pas
mal ça me rend pas moi al'inverse de
ludivine la propreté c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui me tient vraiment à me
dire que ma copine et crado suis chez
moi
ce soit nickel propre pays toujours on
ne sait jamais si par exemple vous étiez
a mené par exemple à venir chez moi à
l'improviste les pas envie de me
retrouver gêné voyez quand vous arrivez
d'accord c'est un principe de vie que je
décline un pop à l'infini par et le
danger j'ai par exemple tu parlais de
pilotes mais je t'en prie dans un dans
mon sac c'est vrai que j'ai une culture
ogm en jeu de rechange pas ce qu'est ce
qui pourrait vous arriver comme accident
oui pardon mais je préfère d'abord comme
ça les valero en faisant la question
j'ai regardé paye pas au sud pour une la
question mais finalement ne pas rentrer
chez moi avoir envoyé un oui on a bien
vu
on a vu jupille et basse c'est vrai que
c'est que la brute et des larges est un
petit mais alors j'imagine
non mais ça me booste la lune par fax au
maire cette entreprise évidence ne pas
voir rentrer dans la maison
pas du tout un mondial mais bon est-ce
qu'il ya eu d'effraction visiblement ils
sont rentrés à la maison alors depuis
propriétaire a quand même coup depuis
changé les séries en se disant on sait
jamais mais ce qu'il avait pu oublier de
laisser là il n'avait pas oublié de
fermer chez lui est ce que comme on a
l'impression tout le temps qu'on est
unique mais peut-être que sous le pot
ils ont trouvé les clés alors que
l'autre propriétaire qui lui attendait
aussi qu'on est à sa vie sur une liste
des raisons pas les bras voilà peut-être
que c'était au même en vacances donc ça
vous chagrine pas plus que ça vous norma
jeane ses fans ça se trouve c'est la fin
de match est complètement bourru que
c'est bourré de maison voilà qui est à
les ranger chez l'autre non mais écoutez
mes filles et moi avons le pouvoir
absolu c'est à dire un super pouvoir
c'est de se transformer en tornade
on n'a pas notre pareil pour mettre le
bordel dans la maison délire dakar
néanmoins ça me ferait quand même un
petit peu mal où je pense donc savoir
que le canada pendant tout de suite mais
voilà que d'un inconnu ou une inconnu
s'introduit chez moi et range tout ça
mais je me sentirai violée dans mon
intimité quoi je crois et c'est pas mal
cambriolage mais à l'envers si vous
voulez mais c'est bien c'est wasquehal
en hiver vous savez qu'un cambriolage
thibault qu'est ce que vous en pensez et
un petit côté fantasmes à un mini
j'imagine après l'émission je rentre les
inconnus chez moi il est fou alors alors
versé le ménage qu'on fait pas la femme
de ménage qui restent
comment enfant c est ce que c'est un
fantasme que vous rentriez à la maison
avec la maison soit soit faite alors que
vous n'avez viennent chez vous ou est-ce
qu'au contraire vous dites comme
christophe qui se sent violée dans son
intimité que vraiment cette solution
c'est pas possible en tout cas moi j'ai
une solution pour piéger la personne qui
veut faire le ménage chez vous regardez
[Applaudissements]
quand on vous dit que ces messieurs
parfois c'est un peu raté là